hi in this video we'll talk about GQ
signaling and specifically we would talk
about the role of IP three and D AG as a
second messenger in this GQ signaling
path and it's also known as colloquially
IP 3 dat pathway so we know that in case
of g-protein coupled receptor signaling
there are several car kind of g-protein
alpha subunits one could be G alpha s
stimulatory there could be G alpha Q or
G alpha I in this particular video we'll
talk about G alpha Q so the signaling
starts when the specific ligands bind to
the g-protein coupled receptor signaling
on the cell surface now as a result
internal to the cell surface the
g-protein trimeric g-protein which is
hanging out from the membrane by several
isoprenoid residues are getting
activated they dislocation to activate
phospholipase C now phospholipase c
cleaves one specific type of lipid
present in the one specific type of
phospholipid present in the membrane
itself known as tip 2 now it Cleaves it
and forms ip3 inositol triphosphate RIS
phosphate for five three four five Tris
phosphate and diacylglycerol now this I
p3 which is produced it's going to move
towards the cytoplasm and diffuse in the
cytoplasm after that it binds to the
specific ip3 receptors on the
endoplasmic reticulum and once
ip3 binds to the endoplasmic reticulum
it allows specific outflux of calcium
into the cytosol now depending upon
which phospholipase is getting activated
these membrane phospholipids could be
cleaved at several residues I mean here
is a diagram in the inset shows where is
the putative cleavage site for
phospholipase c d or phospholipase a
here in this video we only talked about
phospholipase c
now after the calcium level has risin up
in the cytosol just to give you an idea
in inside the e endoplasmic reticulum
calcium levels are in orders of micro
molar whereas in cytosol the calcium
level is kind of several hundreds nano
molar so there is a huge difference
between the cytoplasmic calcium
concentration versus the ER calcium
concentration and a sudden rise in the
calcium concentration works like a
signal so it's also a second messenger
and it is recognized by specific calcium
binding protein known as calmodulin now
calmodulin has specific calcium binding
domains known as EF hand domains which
can recognize calcium and bind to that
now this calcium and calmodulin complex
can in turn activate several kindnesses
such as camp k to camp k4 and several
other cam kinases
all of which phosphor I left several
downstream targets now what are these
downstream targets that these kindnesses
phosphorylate T star these targets could
be very different for ranging from
regulatory elements of metabolic pathway
let's say the camp k2 or any cam kinase
can phosphorylate a regulatory kinase in
a biosynthetic pathway and thereby
regulating the biosynthetic pathway so
and thereby giving a physiological
outcome it can also work at a receptor
level phosphorylating receptor maybe and
thereby control the amount of signal
transduction itself it can also regulate
our transcription factor localization
let's say it phosphorylate one
transcription factor such that it can
localize inside the nucleus or might not
localize inside the nucleus and thereby
controlling indirectly controlling
transcription of several other target
genes now other than that it can
phosphorylate several other cell cycle
controlling genes cell cycle checkpoint
genes and thereby it can have a broad
variety of physiological responses now
we talked about IP 3 which is a clip
product from
pip2 but other than that there is
something sitting in the membrane which
is phe diacyl glycerol now diacyl
glycerol can also bind to protein kinase
C now protein kinase C is a kinase so it
can activate several other downstream
target by phosphorylating them so and
thereby triggering several other
metabolic responses or any other
cellular responses so this was all about
the pathway now we just take a look at
GS signaling and GQ signaling just to
have a good comparison between that now
in GS signaling what happens is G alpha
subunit activates adenylate cyclase
whereas in GQ signaling the G alpha Q
subunit activates fossil like this C now
there is activation of protein kinase a
in G s signaling but as there is
elevation of calcium level and thereby
activation of calcium calmodulin kinase
is in case of GQ signaling so even if
several G protein the the overall
framework is somewhat similar but the G
proteins involved in these pathways are
different especially at the G alpha
subunit level and thereby both these
pathway have different outcome so I hope
you enjoyed this video and this video
was informative for you guys if you
liked my video don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and if you have any
specific questions ask me in the comment
section thank you